foreign
thing what do you mean I I just was like
I'm interested in like um this kind of
stuff like exploration stuff and I just
I saw a tweet from this small up and
coming group that we're gonna go uh on
this little sub thing and all I did was
retweet I said good luck guys well
search continues for a mini sub that
disappeared on a trip to view the
wreckage of the Titanic five people are
on board the Coast Guard in Boston says
that the sub lost contact Sunday about
an hour and 45 minutes into its dive but
we know right now is that the crack look
I would feel bad for like honestly if
you were in a submarine doing some kind
of legitimate work I'd feel bad right
the fact that you were on like doing
this tragedy tourism
the fact that you were going to view no
it's what it is you're literally going
to to get off on viewing of basically
underwater grave site because you and
and you're not even James Cameron so
it's hard to feel as bad for you because
you literally paid 250k to go let's look
at where all these people died
underwater and it's like well I've been
in New Orleans can I make it even worse
for it that's really fun I've been to a
Saints game
for you sure
the Titanic is like the one [__]
shipwreck on the face of the planet that
has the most submarine footage and the
most filming honestly joking aside
he was getting the movie he went down
there and he got more like robots to
film everything and to really like look
at that so like yeah he yeah it is the
most it's probably the most viewed thing
underwater one of the least USS Liberty
yeah like well that's because they
cleaned it up real fast yeah um so let
me merch I feel bad for I felt bad for
them except until I saw this video have
you seen this video
this is a fun little promo video before
it came out this is them talking about
it the trip it's gonna blow your mind
nervous an experimental submersible
vessel that has not been approved or
certified by any regulatory body and
could result in physical injury
disability emotional trauma or death
where do I find
still feel bad for them
well I already didn't because of the
whole oh it's better better than that
though but this is oh it gets funnier
what it gets funnier have you seen
anything hold on have you seen the
inside of the sub
oh no oh
take your shoes off that's customary
okay wow
inside the sub has about as much room as
a minivan so this is not your
grandfather's submersible [__] that
we only have one button that's it it
should be like an elevator you know it
shouldn't take a lot of skill the Titan
is the only five person sub in the world
that can reach Titanic depths 2.4 miles
below the sea theoretically oh [__] that
it's also the only one with a toilet
trust me this is worth it and yet I
couldn't help noticing how many pieces
of this sub seemed and I want you to
listen listen we can use these
off-the-shelf components I got these
from uh camper world
it's not the funniest part that's not
even the funniest part to me that's
funny but wait we run the whole thing
with this game controller
okay man it's not it's a Logitech
bro no I won't even play a video game
with the Logitech anymore there's a lot
to take control I won't even use a
Logitech controller for Hitman no
because it's too wonky to do the
sneaking somebody said he'd probably
died of stick drift
that's I'm not kidding but that's it
that's funny but it's probably not even
oh my God they're so dead as Virgie said
they're so [__] dead
I don't mean to laugh it sucks what were
you thinking to give the crew the USS
Liberty due respect those Chase couldn't
uh couldn't sink or even with the
support of the United States uh just in
case y'all didn't uh hear like myself
season three ride the stemson has begun
yes I knew that also Frozen sold me the
potato chip right so Royce Lopez
barbecue and flavor in store soon I
don't like that so this is running that
sub this makes me anxious I I I'm
claustrophobic to be oh good news you're
not in the sub no thank God yeah but but
no but just thinking about it [__] me
up like I'm claustrophobic to begin with
to be that no I'm with you I'm glad
these people are dead I mean you had to
say that you had various warning signs
and once I saw the game controller I'd
be like you know what you guys can keep
my money it's fine I'm getting out
though let me out let me out let me out
let me out let me out right now
these guys got like 50 feet under under
water and then [__] Water started
spraying into the boat through that fire
or the submarine through that toilet
like a [__] broke fire here's what I
think here's what I well so here's what
I read about this
a gasket just popped and that was it
yeah took Vegas vacationing and you're
putting gum on it like Trevi chased it
at the Hoover Dam and it starts filling
up
this is in the [__] the Logitech
controller gets wet and then you're just
[__] you're [__] that all the all
the lights are like all the lights start
blinking on and off on the Logitech on
all the buttons you're like oh we got
the screen from campers world too
um bro every every submarine even now
like the modern ones all have these
manual overrides and like triple
redundancies and stuff these [__]
are running [__] raw dog here with a
good game controller here's what I heard
I heard that it had
um they lost contact on the way down
which does not bode well but they were
supposed to have this automatic
deployment thing and then for 24 hours
they didn't come back automatically this
timer would pop like a balloon fill it
with air and it would go up now if it
didn't [__] explode and they're dead
which I think is what happened but if it
didn't they had 90 something hours of
air so technically to like tomorrow they
had air they had air till now oh wow
it's not good I the other thing is it's
literal needle in the haystack here like
not literal but to figure needle in the
haystack here right how do you you know
what the chances of them forget finding
them in the next week finding them in
the next 100 years is it's very slim
it's very slim because there's a radar
detector thing but that's not working
right now the last I heard the Coast
Guard was dropping beacons into the
water not to hear to hear if they could
hear voices or hear people tapping can I
can I ask some though why are we doing
all that these people are idiots that's
what I said some some Navy guy said like
or some former Navy guys the U.S Navy
needs to deploy out there now to save
them no no no no no no no no no no no
we're not gonna use my money my tax
money to save a bunch of [__]
billionaires who you just read you just
read the form they signed they signed
the form saying this could possibly
happen and they actually can I say
something that the form didn't say this
could possibly happen reading that form
and looking at that place it said this
is likely going to happen and then you
have this by the way one of the billion
three out of the five three of the five
people in there were billionaires one of
them was also a dude that went on Bezos
uh [__] uh space thing too it's one
of those dudes who does all that kind of
stuff
um this the moment that you look at this
this controller and go so if there's a
Bluetooth sync issue we're dead it's not
even a wire controller merch I want to
point that out no that's what I'm doing
they run out of Double A's
woman we're down and you know those like
cheap cheap Logitech ones too that like
with one battery drains super fast yes
yes yes there's always that what any
cheats to the batteries you know
yeah switching them switching yeah
flipping and putting them on yeah
it seems like you're gonna die
it seems like you're gonna [__] die I
they're [__] man they they this is the
latest update I was on a journey to the
wreck of the Titanic it's operated by
the U.S basically yeah even as Virgie
pointed out it's like the most
photographed filmed videotaped thing
ever you could have watched a YouTube
video Yeah three-fifths in the sub were
billionaires okay with the game
controller yes which uh yeah exactly uh
Ministry of dude Frozen also sold me the
potato chip rights to night wavy very
salty and vinegar waves it's gonna sell
gangbusters in the inner city thank you
sir like what do we like why would you
want to go look at that wreckage anyway
wouldn't you rather go like look at like
coral reefs or something like in in
[__] New Zealand somewhere where it's
pretty nice Ocean's nice
question yeah did they try this out like
in a lake before they went out to the
ocean
oh no no since it wasn't regulated they
weren't out they weren't allowed to use
it in international waters so it was all
or nothing it was here that's it that's
it so like the deepest parts of the
ocean right right right right the parts
that people call well it's funny death
Central you decided to to go you know
what
the Titanic already sank here what's the
chance there's going to be two
calamities in the same spot I mean what
are the odds what are the odds
I can't wait to see James Cameron's in a
movie in a couple years called mini sub
where it's just going to be about the
people dying on the sub
to locate it's gonna be boring it's
gonna be about a little mini toilet
overflowing with piss and [__]
this [__] Cannon shooting in with the
force of all that underwater pressure
we don't mean well we do mean to laugh
it's on board our thoughts are with the
crew members and the families uh on
board of those on board the submersible
at this time and we are doing everything
that we can do to make sure which is
literally nothing because you're the
coast guard for that weekend locate and
rescue those on board as [__]
billionaires come back it's proof to me
that Malik exists I mean yeah
coordination
by the way everybody on this everybody
on the search and rescue mission all
knows they're dead this this is now this
is just a show yeah I know they have to
go through it I know why they're doing
it this is what we call overtime yeah
this is this is just a show right now
that's that's all it is they know
they're dead they're [__] they are
fine let's get out there and justify our
budgets Toontown in the chats are
submersible I think it's classified as a
sinkable now that's not
you don't do that man this people live
service you know did you not they looked
at the logic Tech controller and they
were like what can go wrong I mean if
anything happens I could just piss in
this [__] in this little [__] toilet
in the corner of my minivan
Jesus but what happened